okay Rahm Emanuel do you think Mick
Mulvaney will be thrown under the bus as
Republicans try to defend Trump against
impeachment Mick Mulvaney yes I'm in
Rudy they're gonna go to yeah yeah I
mean there's no one he wouldn't throw
under the bus yeah they're all gonna go
thrown but really together you have 16
wheels you got a lot of people those are
the perfect don't like know in advance
that they're gonna get thrown under the
bus he's thrown man afford and right
Michael Cohen like don't you know going
into this hands with him discard this
just like pick up the paper when they
say that the president doesn't like you
it's like just put the clock on matter
hours he'll be out on the South Lawn say
I've never heard of them Rudy yeah Steve
what do you think of the anonymous
senior official in the Trump
administration writing well like that
book warrant a warning which it seems
like ridiculously late but I mean yeah
this anonymous he wrote the op-ed this
is apparently somebody who is so on the
inside that he can quote Trump on a
daily basis I have trouble with this
because there's only a limited number of
people who it could be wouldn't can they
find this out smells fishy it's like no
[ __ ] I mean he's upstairs reading the
briefing books and doing his job
I mean he's up there but how many people
could it be right how could this person
be this anonymous how many people are in
the White House every day talking to
Trump all the time including up to now
apparently this book goes to when does
the milania's book come out if you
worked in the Clinton or Obama White
House you had a problem with a policy
that hit you morally you left I don't
know I actually don't accept the notion
they anonymously I'm gonna write a book
about how trouble you are you're
troubled leave and speak honestly and
not be anonymous about and then be
called it all out Matas everybody that
leaves
maddis and all the other wrecks all they
tell us and all these other people they
have not sold their soul you're selling
your soul staying there and doing this
and not being up at the stand up there
and say well here's what the other side
you know they would say without they
haven't detected us forget about it I
don't buy that but sometimes that is the
argument Colin Powell they said the same
thing about him he should have left the
Bush administration and I think he did
the nobler thing no I'm gonna stay
because now I'm the only smart person in
the room yeah you think who else is
gonna reign in Cheney and Rumsfeld me he
didn't do it he went to the United
Nations what exactly a talking point
don't know everything you don't know
what they could have they could have
went into Iran if he wasn't there I we
don't know what didn't happen no but we
do know what he had to do to stay and
the price of staying when he did was
lip-syncing what they gave him to read
at the United Nations easy for you to
say I'm scared that I thought suddenly I
agree with scaramouche it's okay
governor Bullock as someone determined
to get money out of politics what are
your thoughts on the news that Tom
Steyer sought to pay for endorsements in
I oh yeah yeah I mean I've been earning
endorsements the old-fashioned way I've
been earning them talking to people not
buying them but I think this does show
even more the overall problem Tom
Starr's the guy who bought his way out
of the debate stage he's buying his way
along and then you have one billionaire
in the race I want to want to be
billionaire in the White House and with
all due respect to Judge Judy I don't
think we need another billionaire in
this race folks turnaround time and time
again and say their voice doesn't matter
in this system if this election I mean
the Kennedys were rich FDR was rich I
feel like we judge people too much not
on the content of their character but
he's too young he's too old he's too
rich he's at that but he's just judge
them on what they are saying and who
they are rich people can be good people
it doesn't mean
Livius to the plight of the Navy look
I'm not saying that rich people can't be
good people but what I'm saying is just
be [ __ ] regular voters just say their
vote doesn't matter or their voice
doesn't matter when someone can turn
around say alright I'll spend 47 million
dollars in the last two hours just
elevate it makes the rest of my money
always win Trump got outspent by Hillary
two-to-one and beter it's when you when
you use Roosevelt and Kennedy they
didn't use their wealth as a way to
prevent other people from having an
opportunity they actually saw their role
in public life is to make sure other
people had a chance to walk through the
door of opportunity and they made major
changes from the GI Bill to actually
also the Peace Corps to give people a
chance and so wealth doesn't describe
anything it's what you do with your life
to make a difference for other people
it's always like a rich guy who's just
done everything he's like there's
nothing left but to rule the world you
don't know if it's for us or them
they're doing it Jud why are you against
Netflix's plan to allow users to speed
up or slow down the playback of movies
and TV shows wait have you heard about
this can't we do this already
YouTube you can do oh you're talking the
actual likes of it yes like you like
like if you're on Apple and you listen
to a podcast there's a button right
there you go like twice yes and then
they're talking about having a button so
like if you just wanted to watch The
Godfather in an hour you could you know
comedy is timing yeah it's something
every movie I make will look like a
Benny Hill sketch
Wow and they must be doing this because
people are demanding this
I won't people demand right you know
people might go like I wish I could you
watch you know this show with a laugh
track let's get around where we'll add a
laugh track to rock me this is probably
because there's just too much content
now yeah there's just so many things
that you want to watch any of it this is
the prompt you don't remember any of it
my wife and I we're watching a narcos
season two and it's been like a year
since season one without and we're like
good guy or a bad guy I could use a
couple cabinet meetings I could have
used a speed channel alright thank you
guys thank you audience
[Applause]
you